let's see if we can better understand
what a cash flow statement for my
simplified shipping truck example
company what it would actually look like
and i say it's simplified because this
is a very simplified income statement
for each of these periods i'm not really
showing all of the expenses and all the
details that you would actually have for
a shipping company but we really just
care about the accounting so let's just
say at the beginning of this fiscal year
when i started this company i had sixty
thousand dollars we know from our
example that we use that sixty thousand
dollars to buy a sixty thousand dollar
truck and on the cash flow statement you
express that saying i spent sixty
thousand dollars on on capital
expenditures sometimes it's property
plant and equipment and so you would
actually put the sixty thousand dollars
right over here on capital expenditures
and hopefully we'll understand this a
little bit and remember the cash flow
statement is really a way of reconciling
the profit with the starting and the
ending cash so let's just think about
this a little bit our profit here if we
just take the number that we have right
over here our profit in the first period
is thirty thousand dollars is thirty
thousand dollars we're assuming nothing
shady is happening with the accounts
payables accounts receivables uh that
they're not changing over the course of
the year and then we have the
depreciation and we want to think a
little bit in this video what is the
depreciation due to the cash flow
statement so i'll just write down the
number first so we have this
depreciation value this is the truck
depreciation now it's not just the
expense value of the truck we're
spreading that cost over three years so
20 000 over three years is the life of
that truck so the depreciation each of
these periods is 20. and what i'm going
to show you here is to figure out the
cash from operations from actually what
is the how much cash is the are the
operations producing we want to add back
we want to add back this depreciation to
the profit so our cash from operations
is going to be 50 000
and it might not seem obvious to you at
first but i want you to think about it
this twenty thousand dollars that we're
showing as an expense in every period it
actually might be a little bit more
obvious if we think about period two or
period three
we're showing it as an expense but no
twenty thousand did not go out of the
door in year two or year three we're
just showing some of the expense from
previous years so no cash went out of
the door so in any of these periods the
depreciation expense should be added
back to the operating profit to figure
out the cash from operations and you
might say wait but we spent that sixty
thousand dollars especially in year one
and that here goes under capital
expenditures that wasn't somehow
the operations didn't push that cash out
the business itself this was just an
investment that we made so it all works
out because we what we see is we got
fifty thousand cash from operations
and that makes sense because our revenue
was a hundred thousand just the labor
the cash labor people salaries were
fifty thousand so that's fifty 000 of
profit this was not a cash expense so
from our operations we had 50 000 but
then we did have the capital
expenditures of 60 000 for the actual
truck so our ending cash would be 60
plus
minus 60. so our ending cash is going to
be 50 000
now it might make a little bit more
sense if we go to the next period our
starting cash here is 50 000
it's our ending cash of the previous
period our profit once again is thirty
thousand dollars
you add the profit to the depreciation
you get a fifty thousand dollar
operating profit same as the previous
year or i should say cash from
operations and that makes sense because
our operations really haven't changed we
have a very very steady business but
this year i have no capital expenditures
i have no capital expenditures i'm using
the same trucks from last year so now
our ending cash we are starting cash was
50 we have 50 000 from operations now
our ending cash is 100 000 so hopefully
that gives you a sense of how of why we
add back depreciation when we figure out
the cash from operations and how it
works out in our cash flow statement